even in those big stadiums though you
when people say things you can hear them
yeah yeah
so what was it ever glow that you were
playing or you oh yes the other day yeah
you were playing a song this song ever
gonna play later and it goes very quiet
and and I have a whole speech about
being kind to each other and accepting
everyone who they are and I thought
everyone's really respecting this
message and then this lady said
something not really to do with that
what did she say she suggested we have
some form of physical contact with each
other so so maybe have a theater show
yeah but I've never had anyone offered
me sex
so I petted the song and it's about that
and then this lady said I'm guilty
I had a tough moment of first of all I
was very flattered and thrilled then I
don't know whether to stop the song
because everyone's gonna wonder what's
going on and so I stopped and then we
had a conversation and then eventually
we know we know we've been together
performance you haven't let anyone shout
that out to you but when you were in
that play I've brought my neighborhood
with Dame Judi Dench Oh Madame desaad
yes that brought a lot of unusual people
well you call a play after the Marquis
de Sade Hume
oh that letter yes letter yes I did get
a letter say [__] me but it might have
been the intention yes I got a letter
after an interview I'd done and this
this man was very very certain that
whoever I was with was I was not meant
to be with and he was the man for me and
I mentioned this to my fellow castmates
and Judy said Oh Rosie she said you have
to go for dinner with him we don't know
anything about him she said well let's
look him up on the internet and got me
what we find I think we found out that
he made kitchens and she said Oh Rosie
she said kitchens she thought my whole
future anyway so I did go for dinner
with him yes because Judy dope tells you
to go for dinner with someone you go
it's possible
if Judy doesn't told you to do something
you do it wouldn't you it was lovely I
mean we're not we weren't together for
very long did you get a kitchen out of
it just yes No oh yeah that's very brave
animation did begin the conversation
actually by saying you probably right
said we looked you up on the Internet me
and Judy he said you probably got the
story about the body washed up in I'm
not joking the story about the body
washed up at my house by the beach I
said never bring that up on a date again
it wasn't with me yes they make it yes I
think we might have got the wrong guy
which is it can easily happen with
certainly is I think the kitchen guy
might have been somebody else so you
didn't even know what he'd look like you
didn't know what he was gonna like it
was a blind oh yes he looked like yeah
this story's become incredibly awkward
[Laughter]
you probably read the story about the
body Graham Norton here if you'd like to
see even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation